[Musica]
[Applauso]
non esistono più le mezze stagioni è
intelligente ma non si applica si stava
meglio quando si stava peggio
la matematica non è un'opinione ai tempi
nostri ci si divertiva con poco
sono sempre i migliori quelli che se ne
vanno
ci sono luoghi comuni che ogni anno
vengono visitati da milioni di persone
iniziare questo top dicendo che stiamo
vivendo la sesta distruzione di massa
quella che forse segnerà la nostra fine
ne sarebbe un altro e quindi non lo
faccio anche se ho appena fatto è che
noi viviamo di contraddizioni e poche
volte facciamo quello che davvero
vorremmo fare è necessario qualcosa o
qualcuno per risvegliarci nel mio caso è
successo questo
una mattina aprendo gli occhi ho
assistito a un alba bellissima mentre
sorgeva il sole inizia da illuminare
enormi strutture artistiche
ero al burning man nel mezzo del deserto
del nevada
un festival che ha più il sapore di un
esperimento sociale un sogno collettivo
un luogo dove migliaia di persone
collaborano alla creazione di queste
gigantesche installazioni il mio lavoro
mi porta spesso in america ed è proprio
lì in america classisti dalla rinascita
di alcuni quartieri periferici
grazie alla forza rigenerativa della
street art winwood dal district a miami
ne è un esempio lampante
pensate che fino agli anni 2000 era un
quartiere industriale periferico pieno
di magazzini e ben poco raccomandabile
ma proprio in quegli anni l'associazione
fra i muri flight decise di creare in
quest'area un open air museum ed invito
artisti provenienti da tutto il mondo a
decorare i muri delle ausl con le loro
opere
oggi ed è il più grande street art
museum del mondo
io sono una sognatrice e l'america mi ha
insegnato che tutto è possibile
quindi mi sono chiesta ma perché non
portare questo sogno
qui in italia nel mio paese e a pensarci
bene in una tela già ce l'avevo questo
edificio anche bruttino lo ammetto ma
l'ha costruito il mio bisnonno ed è
arrivato a me dopo la perdita di mio
padre
l'uomo che mi ha insegnato ad amare il
mare a scalare le montagne
lo stesso uomo che mi ha detto di
inseguire i miei sogni e che per farlo
c'è bisogno di costanza e determinazione
perché i sogni nel cassetto svaniscono e
si trasformano i rimpianti più lo
guardavo più capivo che quel muro poteva
essere la tela perfetta che avrebbe
potuto lanciare un messaggio a me caro
ma ero sola e non avevo la più pallida
idea di come fare un giorno la mia
insegnante di yoga mi disse che per la
religione induista all'universo a
perfetto che c'è equilibrio in tutto e
che quando abbiamo un desiderio ed
agiamo per realizzarlo l'universo cia
seconda si risponde così un'estate
scoprì l'esistenza di queste pitture
magiche in grado di mangiare lo smog
depurando l'area dall 88,8 per cento
dell'inquinamento presente nella stessa
estate con un bilancio attuale
vicepresidente una donna pratica e
sognatrice allo stesso tempo ed una
brillante project manager l'universo
stava rispondendo i tasselli si stavano
inserendo nel modo giusto
di lì a poco andai a new york e conobbi
sempre per caso
federico massa in arte yen a cruz un
artista già noto per la sua sensibilità
verso le tematiche ambientali
lui era l'anello mancante di raccontare
del mio progetto
lui accolse la sfida venne a roma e di
lì a poco mi mandò il primo bozzetto
così ho deciso di fondare una no profit
e urban 20 30 per utilizzare il
linguaggio universale dell'arte al fine
di sensibilizzare sull'importanza e
sull'urgenza di agire nei confronti
delle tematiche ambiente
tali e su quel muro un tempo solo del
mio bisnonno in 21 giorni ha preso vita
avanti in pollution che per me
rappresenta la sintesi perfetta tra arte
e tecnologia
[Musica]
tevere ma già rotto solo
[Applauso]
[Musica]
avevamo realizzato il più grande green
murales d'europa
un'opera da guinness mille metri quadri
di murales antin pollution è in grado di
assorbire l'inquinamento prodotto da 80
veicoli in un giorno è come piantare 30
alberi ad alto fusto e tutto questo
grazie alla pittura che abbiamo scelto
per questo progetto
una pittura a base d'acqua totalmente
naturale antibatteriche ed anti smog
questa pittura agisce in modo molto
simile a quello della fotosintesi
clorofilliana delle piante
sì perché a contatto con la luce genera
un processo fotochimico attraverso il
quale cattura le particelle inquinanti e
le trasforma in sali innocui la poetica
dietro avanti in pollution è un invito a
riflettere sulle azioni contaminanti che
l'uomo ha sull'ambiente raffigura un
airone multicolore una specie in via
d'estinzione che cazzo alla sua preda in
un mare fortemente inquinato è in piedi
su un barile di petrolio ormai è il suo
habitat e delle gocce nere cadono su di
lui in contrasto con quelle bianche
l'airone ignaro che quella preda possa
essere contaminata e quindi per lui
letale se ci pensate bene anche noi
ignoriamo il pericolo che corriamo ogni
giorno quando facciamo la cosa più
naturale del mondo respirare il 90 per
cento della popolazione mondiale
respirare ha fortemente inquinata
l'inquinamento coinvolge nove persone su
dieci in tutto il mondo
vietando 7 milioni di vittime l'anno una
ogni cinque secondi in italia su una
popolazione di 60 milioni di abitanti
abbiamo 38 milioni di veicoli in
circolazione e 90 mila morti l'anno
riconducibili proprio all'inquinamento
atmosferico
eppure continuiamo a disboscare
vedete quanti alberi dovremmo piantare
per avere una riduzione significativa
della ndrine carbonica circa 10 milioni
di chilometri quadrati pari più o meno
all'estensione del canada gli indiani
d'america dicono che non ereditiamo la
terra dai nostri padri ma la prendiamo
in prestito dai nostri figli io non sono
ancora madre che pure è una domanda mi
perseguita ma cosa diremo ai nostri
bambini che non dipendeva da noi che era
un problema al di fuori della nostra
portata all insegneremo a sognare ad
avere speranza ad agire per realizzare
quei sogni per concretizzare quella
speranza
qualche giorno fa ho ricevuto un'email e
ho il piacere di condividerla con voi
gentilissima veronica mi chiamo tommaso
sono uno studente di terni e ho 14 anni
ho visto in televisione quello che ha
fatto a roma
beh io voglio proporre il mio palazzo
che è una città fortemente inquinata
abbiamo l'acciaieria di un inceneritore
dio solo sa quello che respiriamo
infatti sono nato con l'asma
ci sono alcuni giorni che la mattina
quando si va a scuola non si riesce a
respirare per giunto il nostro comune in
un'intera via ha fatto tagliare tutti
gli alberi ho visto che voi con la
pittura riuscito a cambiare l'aria mi
piacerebbe che lei o chi lavora per lei
dipinge se il mio palazzo che in centro
in una zona molto trafficata anche per
far capire grandi che comandano che
anche noi giovani abbiamo un cervello e
che forse per il nostro futuro vogliamo
di più e se siamo su questa terra
dobbiamo curarla il più possibile spero
che mi risponda grazie tommaso ecco la
mia nuova sfida
il mio sogno è quello di concretizzare
progetti come questo sto immaginando
persone disposte a donare le facciate
dei loro edifici artisti disponibili a
lavorarci sopra ed un'operazione di
crowdfunding
capace di coinvolgere tutti come possono
a partecipare per sentirsi parte di un
cambiamento di una metamorfosi perché
quei muri e quelle opere siano davvero
di tutti
immagino un grido fatto di colori di un
pensiero di comunione un mondo dove
guardando un muro si possa dire questo è
nostro perché questa è casa nostra e
quindi no non esistono più le mezze
stagioni è intelligente ma non si
applica si stava meglio quando si stava
peggio la matematica non è un'opinione
ai tempi nostri ci si diverte con poco
ci si divertiva con poco perché
concludere questo top dicendo che il
futuro è nelle nostre mani
sarebbe un altro luogo comune l'ennesimo
ed io lo faccio perché è così
[Applauso]
[Musica]